uh here we go wrapper and potential
presidential candidate County Woods has
reportedly fired White House supremacist
White House supremacist Nick Fuentes and
reinstated right-wing provocateur
provocateur Milo yiannopoulos and his
long term long shot 2024 campaign West
has also reportedly ousted Ali Alexander
2020 election dinar and organizer of the
stop the steel movement the Annapolis
allegedly sent emails to Fuentes and
Alexander informing them they were
terminated and had been
and he had been appointed director of
political operations West 2024 campaign
has been marked by stops and starts last
year he ran for president and received
only 0.04 percent the popular vote
National nationally his business Empire
collapsed after he made a series of
anti-Semitic comments uh and praised the
Adolf Hitler Annapolis Rose to
prominence as an editor of Breitbart
News but lost his job after video clips
emerge of him saying it was possible for
13-year-old boys to have perfectly
consensual sexual relations with adults
so what are your thoughts on the story I
think Milo yiannopoulos is a genius
he's he he is planning things that you
don't even know
and then he they are working and I am
not surprised to hear that he is once
again working with yay because I
wouldn't be surprised if this was his
plan the entire time
uh I don't know what else to say about
it I mean it feels all A bit chaotic but
you know from from what I know of Milo
from the conversations I've had with him
from what people have heard him talk
about you know this dude has a plan
you know he's doing something he's not
just sitting there throwing dart boards
at the wall he's like he's got something
going on
what is that something I don't know I
don't know I think he wants revenge on
Republic on the Republican establishment
I think he wants revenge
um for dedicating so much of his life to
Trump Maga and the conservative movement
only to be insulted and thrown out and I
think he is particularly someone who's
formidable and clearly has the means to
strike back and and be successful in
doing so I'm not saying it's like he's
guaranteed to win whatever it is he is
planning but now here he is rehired by
Kanye West whatever his plan is it seems
to be working
you define this working yeah oh yeah
Define define working what is working
because it's
if Miley Annapolis is mad at the
Republican establishment yeah and then
he gets Kanye West Into The Fray in
politics and he gets you have the House
GOP tweeted something like uh musk Kanye
Trump or whatever and then yay goes on
Alex Jones's show and starts praising
Hitler causing damage for the
Republicans like I think he's getting
his revenge in some in some form like
working is I'll put I'll put it this way
if what he was doing wasn't working we
would not be talking about him so I
don't know what his plan is but he has
maintained his position and his
influence and his effect there you go
Kanye Elon Trump they tweeted that out
they deleted it yeah now I wonder how
much Milo had to do with that
Judiciary GOP
yeah Kanye what does that mean exactly
they were just saying like they I guess
they like these guys right Elon was
buying Twitter Trump is Trump Kanye was
speaking out in support of trump and
things like that and now because there's
a fascinating thing that occurs in this
country in in terms of what I call cult
uh cultural context
the context of the time is not praising
what Kanye said about Adolf Hitler it
doesn't matter because what the left
will do is if if you praise Kanye 10
years ago for being a great musician you
say that you think he's a genius they
will cut the date out and just take the
tweet and say you praised Kanye West how
dare you that's so funny and you're like
that was 10 years ago it doesn't matter
doesn't matter that was during College
Dropout yeah
I loved him not how it works wow they
will they they strip the context around
so uh I'll give you an example I once
said uh there's a video of me where I'm
like I don't trust the New York Times I
trust Dave Rubin right if I'm if if I'm
looking at this and Dave Rubin I'm not
going to trust what New York Times says
what they do is they cut that particular
quote and they say look how stupid Tim
Poole is trusting Dave Rubin over New
York Times it was referring to one
specific story
I can't remember exactly the details but
what will happen is
there will be a reporter reporting on
your life Patrick and then your friend
will come out and make a video saying
like look if I'm reading about this I
trust Patrick I don't trust the New York
Times and then they're gonna be like how
stupid of him to trust a podcaster over
over the media it's like dude the story
was about him and the job he had why
would I trust an external company about
him personally but what they do is
they'll strip out the context to make it
sound like you're speaking generally
another example is I said
there's a clip of me going Infowars is
like a right-wing Huffington Post blah
blah and then they're like Temple
actually thinks Infowars is credible
news the specific context of the story
is there were journalists on the ground
covering Donald Trump's rally their goal
is to try and capture people the way of
having to post to do like they're like a
right-wing Huffington Post so in one
specific context I'm saying this thing
they strip that out that works so what I
look again I don't I don't know what
what Milo's plan is or what yay's plan
is for that matter but if Milo is able
to get himself into the highest like
Kanye's probably the most famous guy on
the planet or one of them
he's he's got access he's doing
something you just don't know you still
know what he's doing but I mean let's
talk about what not working would be we
wouldn't be talking about it nowhere we
wouldn't know where he was and the fact
of the matter is there's probably seven
billion people you can't name whose plan
is not working
yeah that's a good point
I don't know we'll see what's going to
add a very interesting conversation with
Milo uh one time six years ago seven
years ago in Florida uh but uh you know
the guy's definitely a great marketer
didn't he just start so Rob you were
telling me something about he started
called Clinic
uh yeah it's a conversion Therapy Clinic
here in Florida in Sarasota I believe
um it is a what does it do Rob I I
believe it conversion like people from
Democrats to Republicans uh no it comes
in and slaps you in the head uh from I
believe homosexuality to heterosexuality
this is Milo let me bringing them back
let's talk about how the media lies I
had Miley Annapolis on my show and uh
and we talked about the media says
you're straight now Milo says I never
said that Milo explained that he is a
gay man who is Christian recognizes that
these behaviors and and practices are
bad so he will abstain from them and
thus be uh celibate
the media then started reporting he's
claiming he's now straight but that is
not what he said at all and so I
actually asked him I was like so you're
still attracted to men he's like yes and
I'm like okay but you're not gonna be
hooking up with me he's like no that's
wrong and I'm like oh okay so you're
celebrating he's like yes oh wow so it's
like that's a very different story to
what the media was yeah how long does
celibate last though foreign
is now preparing to open a controversial
conversion therapy facility in Florida
the processor in an interview with the
post the former Breitbart News editor
revealed his plans to launcher what is
that reperative Therapy Clinic to help
other people go through the same Journey
as I am on myself despite the lack of
data shown effectiveness of the exercise
ask him what it hit what sense he is ex
gay Annapolis told the post that he is
an ongoing process of trying to reorient
his homosexuality but for now is in a
stage of abstinence and enjoys using the
term to troll his critic he just tells
you what he's doing yeah exactly x gay
right I still think of conversion
therapy plays for democrat or republican
is pretty funny so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]